okay I don't want to spend like a crazy
amount of time on this story today
because it's not that it's not a huge
story it is a huge story but I believe
that this story is ultimately going to
do very little in terms of moving the
needle towards the goal of removing
Donald Trump because his followers have
been primed to dismiss stuff that isn't
good for Trump as fake news but it is an
important story so let's discuss it a
little bit and maybe later in the week
we'll have more more information about
it over the weekend news reports came
out that Russia was offering bounties
and Depp that means it's like a cash
bonus right bounties were being offered
by Russia to Taliban linked militants
for killing American soldiers and
coalition forces in Afghanistan and
there's a lot here historically Russia's
political links to Afghanistan go back a
very long time both Democrats and
Republicans in the United States have
had any number of abortive ventures into
dealing with Afghanistan from a
geopolitical standpoint but the the
facts here are really about what Trump
knew if he knew it and when he knew it
and this allegedly was happening behind
the scenes Russia offering bounties on
killing US and coalition forces in
Afghanistan while Donald Trump was
publicly sucking up to the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and the story
goes that months ago American
intelligence agencies concluded that a
Russian military intelligence unit was
offering secret cash bonuses for killing
these coalition troops which include
American troops and this made it we know
to the National Security Council by
March of this year meaning we'll talk
later about what Trump knew and when he
knew it but at minimum it made it to the
National Security Council the
allegations certainly in other countries
like in the UK they were also aware at
the highest levels of their government
and intelligence services about these
alleged cash bounties for killing their
troops and that leaves us with two
possibilities about Donald Trump
possibility one is Trump knew about this
at the time and he was still sucking up
to Putin or Trump didn't know about this
at the time which means someone has to
get fired for keeping the president in
the dark about something so major but
I'll tell you how it's all being spun
and we may or may not really figure out
what's going on
so if Trump was not briefed about this
alleged cash bounty if he didn't know
that's a major problem because we know
it was discussed at the National
Security Council level and we know that
our allies were aware of it so the the
the initial question was does Trump know
the White House said nothing for the
first 24 hours after the story broke no
comment no comment no comment and then
the White House and Trump seemed to
coordinate the response that Trump had
no idea
Trump hadn't been told he just wasn't
aware that this was going on but again
Trump always has to go a little bit
further and Trump starts to imply he
wasn't told because it's fake news which
is just absolutely perfect for his
supporters who have been primed to
believe exactly this Donald Trump
tweeting quote nobody briefed or told me
vice president Pence or chief of staff
mark meadows about the so-called attacks
on our troops in Afghanistan by Russians
as reported through an anonymous source
by the fake news New York Times so
understand that first Trump is
misstating the story the story is about
Russian bounties Russian bounties if
indeed troops are killed it's not
necessarily a story about Russian
attacks although there could have been
some he again brings up the anonymous
source thing as reason to think that
it's all fake news he goes on to say
everybody is denying it and there have
not been many attacks on us nobody's
been tougher on Russia than the Trump
administration with corrupt Joe Biden
and Obama Russia had a field day taking
over important parts of Ukraine where is
hunter probably just another phony Times
hit job just like their failed Russia
hoax who is their source so this is like
the standard operating procedure for
Trump
calls the attacks so called he again
says it's all based on an anonymous
source can't trust that attacks Obama
and Biden and brings out the fake news
moniker so we don't actually know the
truth if Trump was briefed and just
decided to say he wasn't well then he's
a liar but we already know that he's a
liar so that wouldn't be new if Trump
was briefed but forgot which we've heard
Trump has no memory to speak of
whatsoever that again raises the
cognitive decline and fitness for the
job sorts of questions and then if Trump
really was not briefed which is the
story they are telling us don't heads
need to roll
don't people need to be fired for not
briefing the president about this maybe
not because their new position as I
alluded to is the reports while
discussed by the national security
council were so unbelievable so not
credible that it didn't make sense to
brief the president to which I say
that's absolutely BS I mean that's just
absolute yes if it gets to the NSC
and they determine we don't think this
is true
you still briefed the President on it
unless again the if you don't briefed
the president because you want plausible
deniability if you want to hide the
president from this so that he can later
deny having knowledge of it that's a
whole other set of problems
remember Benghazi the endless bogus
hearings that uncovered nothing this
actually warrants hearings and actually
warrants putting people under oath so we
can figure out was Trump told or was
Trump not told who's lying where is the
responsibility I wouldn't be shocked to
hear that officials under oath would
testify you know we we did tell Donald
Trump whether or not Donald Trump
listened because he's often watching a
TV in the background while he's getting
his presidential daily briefings whether
Trump remembers that's a separate
question they are for now insisting on
Trump didn't know that's a terrible
defense it's the one that you maybe put
out there if the truth is even worse as
is often the case with this
administration hopeful
we'll learn more about this in the
coming week I'm really excited that one
of our sponsors today is helix sleep I
sleep on a helix mattress at home I
absolutely love it and that's why I
reached out to them about sponsoring the
David Pakman show buying a mattress in
the past was always a huge guessing game
for me I didn't know what I actually
needed I didn't know what I would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have and their tool
matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me it's cool enough at night
it's the right firmness I generally just
do way better sleeping these days
because of the mattress hilux was
awarded number one best overall mattress
for the last two years by both GQ and
Wired magazine it is well deserved I can
tell you firsthand every helix mattress
comes with a 10 year warranty you can
try the mattress risk-free for 100
nights and they will even come pick it
up at your house if you don't love it
but I know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 dollars off your
order and you'll get two super premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video